[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Welcome
to lecture three.
Today and on
Wednesday, we're going
to talk about time preferences
and particular theory.
We're going to talk a lot
about a lot of applications,
a lot of applications
that are sort of close
to your real world, including
procrastination of problem
sets, all sorts of other choices
such as credit card debt,
and so on, and so forth.
Can you be a little quiet?
Thank you.
Think of the lectures
today and on Wednesday
building some framework
and some sort of structure
and how to think
about these things.
It's a little drier than
maybe other lectures, in part
because it's about theory, and
about writing down a model,
and trying to think
about the world.
Partially we're doing
that to sort of try
to explain behaviors
that we see in the world,
partially we do that
because at the end,
we try to think
about welfare and how
to evaluate certain
outcomes-- is
that good or bad-- certain
policies and things to do,
which later in the course
we're going to talk about.
But for that you,
need some structure
how to think about
some of those things.
At the heart of
it, a lot of this
is about procrastination, about
choices between the present
and the future.
Your problem set, in part, is
also about procrastination.
It will be posted later
today, probably late.
Please do let us know if
you have any questions.
As I said, please be on time.
Do the readings.
There will be
random pop quizzes.
They will be at the
beginning of the class,
so you should be on time.
The laptop section
is still over there.
If you want to use your laptop,
it should be there, ideally,
in the front, in part
because you're not
going to bother others.
I saw quite a few people
using their phones
in class in previous classes.
Try to not do that.
That's not good for you.
You will not be able to take
away much from the class.
Multitasking is very
hard for people to do.
Again, I'll show you
some evidence on that.
As I said, the problem set
will be posted shortly.
If you have any questions,
please do let us know on Piazza
and help others answer them
or answer them for others.
I have office hours,
usually Tuesday afternoons.
Please sign up for them.
I'm very happy to meet you.
It's very hard for me to meet
people or get to know you
in the large class otherwise.
So please come to office hours.
I'm happy to talk to
you about anything
you're interested
in, ideally related
to behavioral economics.
So let me give you an overview
of this and the next lecture.
We're going to talk first
about exponential discounting.
Why are we talking about
exponential discount?
This is the workhorse model
of classical economics.
This is how economists usually
think about choices over time.
Second, we're going to identify
some problems with this model,
and try to think about why
is this model perhaps not
explaining things well,
at least in some settings?
And how could we
improve on that?
I'm going to propose an
alternative model, which
is the quasi-hyperbolic
discounting model.
And then we're going to
talk about sophistication
and naivete, which is the
idea that if you think
you have different preferences
in the present form
in the future, then it becomes
very important to understand.
Do you actually know
what's going on?
Do you know that in the
future you might be impatient,
or do you perhaps think
that in the future,
I will be very patient,
and then perhaps make
some mistakes accordingly?
I'll get to this in more detail.
So it's first
important to notice
that any choice, essentially
almost any choice you
make, almost always involves
some choice over time.
Essentially, some trade-off
between the present,
between some cost and
benefit that you might occur
in the very short run, and
some costs and benefits
that you might enjoy
or incur in the future.
What examples do we have?
What choices over
time do we face?
Yes.
STUDENT: Savings
versus consumption.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Uh-huh.
And how do you decide
how much to save?
STUDENT: Depending on your
preferences and interests,
right?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So you have the
choice, for example,
if you think about should I
save some money, let's say,
for next semester or next year.
So your choice is either
to consume the money now
in various ways--
eat food or whatever
you would like to do with it,
spend it on various activities.
So if you save, if you
make the decision to save,
you have to give
up some money now,
and you get some
benefits in the future.
The benefits in the future
are determined by the interest
rate, as you say.
If you have a savings
account or the like,
you can essentially get
some benefits in the future.
And then you have some
costs in the present, which
would be essentially
not consuming now,
and some benefits in the
future, which is getting
that money in the future.
And then you need to somehow
decide is that worth doing.
There's some cost and benefit.
We need to aggregate somehow,
whether to make that choice.
Any other choices
you make over time?
Yes.
STUDENT: Whether to
go to college or not
or start working right
away and make some money
or delay that income.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So I actually have this
example here-- going to school.
It has some costs and benefits.
And what are the costs and
benefits of doing that?
STUDENT: You
sacrifice four years
or whatever right
now versus supposedly
a higher income later on.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So you have direct
costs of education,
which is tuition in many cases.
Sometimes that's sponsored,
but often there's tuition.
It's quite a bit of money.
It's also the opportunity cost,
which is often forgone wages.
You could be working
otherwise and make more money.
There's the joy of pain
of going to school.
Some might think it's positive.
Some might think it's negative.
And then there's future
wages, which in many cases,
at least for you
guys, tend to be
higher from going to college.
If you do a PhD, that
might not be the case.
I'm not sure if the
TA's are here, but yes.
I'm sorry for that.
And then you have to decide
are you going to school or not.
What do you need to do
is you need to determine
the utility, the value of each
of these costs and benefits.
And they occur in
different points in time.
You need to make some estimates.
And then, of course, there's
risk and other issues involved.
You might not have full
information, and so on.
But assuming that
all away, suppose
you knew all the costs and
benefits of going to college.
Then you have to decide,
is that worth doing?
So somehow you need to aggregate
these costs and benefits
over time by putting
appropriate weights
on different periods
in time, and decide,
should I do this or not.
OK.
Yes, any other similar
choices that people make?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
For example, you
could think about
should I do a problem set?
Should I come to class?
Should I study for
an exam, and so on.
Often, there's costs
and benefits involved.
Often, the costs are immediate.
You have to work
on the problem set.
That might not be pleasant.
You have to study for the exam.
You could be doing other
things instead that you
can't do because of that.
And then there's going to
be rewards in the future,
usually in the terms either
through increased knowledge
that might be useful for
other things in the future,
or through better grades, or
whatever you might be rewarded
from having more knowledge.
And then, again, there might
be uncertainty involved
because it could be that you
might not fully know what
the costs and benefits are.
It could be that
it's sort of risky.
You might come to class or
not come to class depending
on whether there's a pop quiz or
not, so there's risk involved.
But assuming that away,
there's essentially
benefits and costs
in the present,
and then benefits and costs,
potentially, in the future.
And again, somehow you have to
aggregate these and weigh them
in various ways.
Any other choices?
Yes.
STUDENT: Exercise.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Exercise, yeah, exactly.
Exercise is a good one.
Again, in the present,
you might not enjoy it.
Some people might
actually enjoy it a lot.
Somebody would tell
me he was addicted
to exercise-- that also happens.
But usually, people, at
least in the short run,
tend to not like
exercise that much.
But I think it's useful for
them to do, in part because they
feel better afterwards,
in part because they
have long-run benefits.
Maybe they're in better
shape eventually.
Maybe the healthier eventually.
Maybe they'll live longer
eventually, and so on, and so
forth.
And again, what
you need to do is
you have some
costs and benefits.
You have the costs of getting
ready, getting out of the door,
and getting yourself to do it.
That often is costly.
There's the cost of exercising
itself, which often is costly,
maybe not.
But then the benefits
are often in the future,
often really far
away in the future.
So if you really were
eating healthier, often
the same thing--
essentially, you might not like
eating spinach and vegetables
in the present.
Some people, of
course, love that,
but often, then,
the benefits come
in the form of improved
health many, many years out.
And again, what
you need to do is
you need to quantify somehow
the costs and benefits
of certain actions.
And then you need to aggregate
the costs and benefits somehow,
to be able to make a choice.
Is that a good
idea or a bad idea?
Do you want to do this or not?
A number of different examples--
here's another example
of something that's
very trivial--
purchasing an
expensive software.
You have to spend some
money of doing it.
That usually entails
negative utility.
People don't like
to give up money.
Second, there's
pain and frustration
of learning the software.
Again, that's often
negative utility.
And then there's
mastery, which is
positive utility from knowing
or learning the software,
until it becomes obsolete.
So there's a stream of positive
utility sometime in the future.
Now, how do you decide whether
to purchase the software?
Well, you determine the
value of the utility
of costs and benefits somehow.
And we're going to talk about
in some degree how to do that.
And then once you
have that, you need
to weigh the costs and
benefits, and try to aggregate,
and try to figure out, is
this a good idea or not.
There's another choice,
which we're actually
going to talk about when
we talk about welfare
and about policies.
Overall, it's deactivating a
social media account, in part
because there's a very
nice study that actually
studies precisely that.
So if you think about
deactivating a social media
account--
Facebook, Twitter, Instagram,
whatever people are using--
there's different costs
and benefits involved.
And you can argue
about what those are.
Part of that is the direct cost
of deactivating the account.
Often, that's a
tedious thing to do.
You have to figure
out how to do it.
Often, companies try
to not make it too easy
for you to actually do that.
You might want to archive
some pictures, or whatever,
and so on.
Often, that's a
tedious thing to do.
There's often a short-run
adjustment cost,
where you want to be in
touch with your friends.
Maybe it's harder to find
out where the parties are,
or whatever,
whatever things are.
So often, there's some
adjustment cost, likely also
negative.
And then there is
some long-run impact
on your social life,
on your mental health,
on your happiness,
and so on, that
could be positive or negative.
Assuming that perhaps
a positive, then again,
you have to think about
short-run negative costs
and benefits.
You have to learn about,
think about what those are.
Again, they might be uncertain.
But to the extent that you
could tell what they are,
then you have costs and benefits
at different points in time.
And when you make
that choice, you
have to figure
out whether that's
worth doing by aggregating them
somehow to some point in time
and, saying yes,
I'll do it, or not.
And we'll get back
to this in, I think,
something like lecture
20 or so, where
there is a study that was
encouraging people to, in fact,
precisely do that, and look at
happiness and other outcomes,
mental health, and so
on, among students.
OK, so what are other
important choices over time?
If you think about almost
anything that you can think of,
any choice that you make in
your life, almost any of these
involve some aspects of time.
So if you think about investing,
saving, borrowing, credit card
spending, and so on, that
involves choices over time.
If you think about
education, often, there's
costs in the present,
benefits in the future.
If you think about any sort
of health investments--
eating healthy, taking
your medication,
brushing your teeth, exercising,
and so on, if you think
about sleeping,
often sleep involves
choices between the
present and the future.
You think about watching movies
at night-- that's fun to do.
But often, that comes out
like pain on the following
day in various forms.
Eating patterns as
well, dating arguably
involves sort of
costs and benefits
in the present and the future.
People make different choices.
Again, there's all sorts of
other aspects involved as well,
including risk,
information, and so on.
But what I'm pointing
out is many choices
that people make have
some aspects that involve
different points in time.
And you have to figure out
how to weigh these utility
streams in some
ways accordingly.
Now, here's a broad
history of how economists
have thought about this.
And it's interesting
to read, in fact.
And this is what the Frederick
et al. article talks about.
In fact, economists sort of
went full circle in some way.
So it started with a
very complicated model
of a production, the
amount of labor allocated
to the production
of capital that
depends on the effective
desire of accumulation,
which is a bit of a mouthful.
But essentially,
there was lots of
rich psychological
considerations involved
in trying to explain how
people make choices over time.
People thought about
self-control, self-restraint,
the bequest motive, how
much they think about
their children,
anticipatory utility--
people like to save because they
like to think they'll be happy
in the future--
and so on, and so forth.
And it was a very complicated
model of intertemporal choice
that people had
been thinking about.
At some point, then
Bohm-Bawerk, who
was an Austrian
economist at some point
realized or proposed that the
interest rate, in some sense,
is just a price.
So if you think about doing
something or saving some money
from today until next
year, it's really
just like choosing between
apples and bananas.
When you choose between
apples and bananas,
there's a relative price, which
is the price of apples divided
by the price of bananas.
If you think about
choices over time,
if you think about consuming
$1 today versus $1 next year,
the interest rate or 1
plus the interest rate
is the relative price of that.
So for any dollar
that I now consume,
I could get 1 plus r
dollars in the future.
That's just the relative
price of consumption
now versus in the future.
So you could think of--
the same way we think
about apples and bananas
and optimizing between
those, the same way we
can think about consumption
in the present and the future,
which are just sort of like
different goods over time.
And so Irving Fisher,
then, came up and said,
let's just write down a
two-good in difference diagram.
This is exactly the
indifference diagram
that you've seen in like 1401
or other introductory Micro
classes.
Still, there were actually
many psychological factors
discussed, like personal
factors that determine
how much you save, and so on.
But it was progress
towards that.
Now, what is the Fisher diagram?
The Fisher diagram looks
something like this.
This is what you should
be familiar with from,
again, 1401.
What do we see here?
What is this?
Yes.
STUDENT: I guess it traces
between [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
So we have here choices between
two goods, call them good
a and good b.
There's a consumption. c a
is consumption of good a,
c b is a consumption of good b.
We have a budget
set, essentially,
which is determined here by how
much your budget's constrained,
which is the triangle
line that you see there.
The slope of that
budget set is determined
by the relative price.
That's essentially the
p a divided by p b.
And then we have what's called
an "indifference curve," which
essentially is the curve
that makes us indifferent
between combinations
of two goods.
And we choose the point
on the budget line
that's the furthest
out, that gets us
in the furthest
indifference curve.
So that's 1401 that you
should be all familiar with.
In part, that's
what was discussed
in recitation on Friday.
Now, Fisher then
pointed out when
you think about
choices over time,
in fact, that's
exactly the same thing.
Think about it two periods,
period one and period two.
We have, essentially,
a budget line, again,
which is the budget set.
Again, that's what was
discussed in recitation
on Thursday and Friday.
The difference here, of
course, is then the price.
The relative price is determined
by the interest rates.
So 1 plus r is now essentially
the relative price, or 1 over 1
plus r, that determines
essentially how much we
can maximally consume.
Again, the triangle
that you see here
is the potential set
that you consume.
And then again, you have
a indifference curve
that tells us the
sets of points that we
are indifferent between,
good one and good two.
And we choose what's furthest
out on the indifference curve.
So essentially, we
can apply any tools
that we have from 1401
or any Micro class,
from choices between
apples and bananas
to choices between period
one and period two.
And so what we're
sort of ignoring
here is then in period
one and period two,
how are we going
to spend the money?
So we think of c1 and c2
as consumption bundles.
Think about this
like how much money
is spent on certain
consumption goods in period one
versus period two, ignoring
whether you buy apples
or bananas, just how much money
do you want to spend in period
one, how much money do you
want to spend in period two,
ignoring how exactly are
you going to divide it,
assuming that you're going
to get this right in terms
of choosing within the
period what's best for you.
Any questions on that?
OK, so that gets us
to the workhorse model
in economics, which is
Samuelson's discounted utility
model.
Paul Samuelson is a very
famous economist who
was at MIT for many,
many years, one
of the founders, if you
want, of modern economics,
and the MIT Economics
Department as it is right now.
And what Samuelson proposed
was a non-graphical version
of that, where he said,
let's write down some math.
Let's write down
the representation.
How should we think about
utility maximization?
And what essentially he was
proposing is to say at time t,
people maximize their discounted
utility, which is just
the sum of discounted utility
where there is a factor
delta, which
determines how much we
care about the present
versus the future.
So we have, essentially, these
instantaneous utilities, u t,
u t plus 1, u t
plus 2, and so on.
This is your utility
at each point in time.
Think of time as being discrete.
In a sense, time
could be years, time
could be days, and the like.
Think of them perhaps
as years for now.
There's your t, your t
plus 1, your t plus 2,
your t plus three, and so on.
u t summarizes, in some sense,
how you feel in that year
overall in terms of utility.
That's your utility in
that particular period.
It could also be daily.
It could be how you
feel on a certain day,
could be hourly, and so on.
That's just a matter
of definition.
And again, u t is a function of
all activities that are going
on in that particular year.
That could be consumption,
leisure, all the other things
that are going on.
That's sort of
like in some sense,
we abstract away what happens
within that particular time
period.
We're just summarizing
all the things
you're doing in that year
yield to a certain utility.
And now the question is, how do
we aggregate these utilities?
How do we decide between
different options
when the u t's differ
across different options?
Now, what's coming
in here, then,
is the discount factor
delta, which you see above,
which essentially is
telling you how much is util
or an amount of utility,
a unit of utility,
worth in the future
compared to the present.
And so what you see here is
a very simple functional form
of doing that.
Everything that's in the
future is discounted.
Usually, we think of delta
being smaller than 1.
So delta could be something
like 0.9, 0.8, or the like.
So if you're in period t, period
t plus 1 is discounted by 0.9.
Period two would
be then discounted
by 0.9 to the power of 2,
and so on, and so forth.
And so delta is essentially
a very simple way
of replacing a very
complex psychology, how
we think about
choices over time,
by saying let's just assume
that people over time
have a constant way of
discounting the future.
And it's taken on a
simple mathematical form
of exponentially doing so.
Any questions on that?
Yes.
STUDENT: Why was Samuelson's
model adopted so widely?
I mean, so it said
in the reading
that it was very simple and very
pretty, but he's very much--
it seemed like oversimplified
a lot of the research that
had been done in the past.
Why were people
so quick, I guess?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
STUDENT: Was it,
like, the fashion
to have these [INAUDIBLE]?
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Yeah, so I think
one has to think a little bit
about where things are coming
from, in the sense
that to start with,
nobody had formalized
some of these choices
that people were making.
In some sense,
Samuelson was, like, OK,
we have to assume something.
So let's assume
exponential discounting.
That's a simple thing to do.
So let me just make that
assumption as a first pass.
He actually never thought
this is the right model,
or this is a normative model
how people should behave,
or the like.
That was all coming later.
He was just proposing
something that's tractable.
And for tractability,
he was proposing that.
Now, it's important
to understand
for a lot of
behavioral economics,
a lot of neoclassical economics,
the traditional economics,
simplicity is good.
So usually, we like to
simplify a lot of choices.
And when things are simple,
you can, in a tractable way,
analyze things in the world.
And for many problems
in the world,
like for example,
economic growth,
or like how the economy
evolves as a whole,
and so on, some of these, the
exponential discounting model
might actually be the
right model in some ways.
Or if you think about
how managers of firms,
or whatever, et cetera,
behave, in some ways
that might be the
right-- or the economy
as a whole-- that might be
the right model overall.
So in some sense, the
answer is kind of like, A,
some choices are actually
explained reasonably well
with exponential discounting.
B, it was simple and easy to do,
and you had to start somewhere.
And then C, I guess people tend
to stick to traditional things.
So in some ways, once you
have written down a model,
and people have written papers
and invested their career
in it, they tend to defend that,
where in fact, maybe that's not
the right thing to do, and
become dogmatic about it.
But that's now changing.
And exactly as you say, there's
problems with this model,
and we're going to talk
about those right now.
Now let me tell you a little
bit about some definitions,
just to be clear what
we're talking about.
So one is, what's a
"discount function,"
what's a "discount rate," and
what's a "discount factor?"
So these are just definitions.
A discount function
essentially is
when you have a stream of future
utilities, u t, u t plus 1,
u t plus 2, and so
on, and so forth, you
have to write down
a function how
to weigh these in the future.
So d of tau, as I'm
calling it, is essentially
giving you this
discount function
that specifies essentially
all the weights
that you're putting on future
utilities and future periods.
That could be that
functional form.
Could be anything.
That's just a very
general definition.
Now, what's the discount rate?
It's essentially
the rate of decline
of the discount function.
We call that rho and rho
of tau, which essentially
is just the derivative
with respect to time
divided by the discount
function at that point in time.
And the negative of that,
because we think usually as
positive as in the discount
function tends to decline,
as in stuff that's
further away in the future
you put less weight on than
stuff that's closer to you
or closer to the present.
And so again, rho
of tau specifies
the rate at which value a
util declines with delay.
And then finally, what does
exponential discounting do?
Exponential discounting
specifies a specific functional
form of the discount function.
What does that mean?
Essentially, we just take the
discount function, d of tau,
and what Samuelson was
doing then was essentially
just proposing a specific
functional form, saying,
OK, let's try that one.
That's a simple thing to do.
Why do you choose that one?
Well, it's delta to
the power of tau.
The discount factor
now is delta.
This is essentially when
you think about two periods,
how much weight do you put
on each of those periods.
Let me just go
back for a second.
Here, when you think about
going from u t to u t plus 1,
you just add an
additional delta.
And going from u t plus 1 to u
t plus 2, you add another delta,
and so on.
That gives you essentially
the relative weights
between two adjacent periods.
Now crucially, as you see
here in that functional form,
this is constant.
So every time you have a time
period, you go to the future,
you add another delta.
And that's an assumption.
So that's a very
convenient thing to do.
In part what it tells
you, then, is also
that the discount rate
is constant over time.
Again, so that you
could do some math,
and calculate the discount
rate, if you do that,
you'll find out
that the discount
rate is minus log delta, which
is approximately 1 minus delta.
That is to say, not only is
the discount factor constant,
but also the discount
rate is constant.
And that's an assumption,
again, that's made by Samuelson.
So you can do that math.
We can also do some of
that in recitation in case
you have questions.
Now let me give you
an example on how
does that help us
think about how
people make choices over time.
Student Amy considers
writing a term paper today
so as to give herself a
free evening in the future.
So this is essentially the idea
that the student now, tonight,
has some stuff to do.
There's some opportunity
costs right now.
An outside option--
she could watch TV,
she could meet her
friends, or whatever,
or she could write
her a paper right now.
The paper, if you write
the paper right now,
it comes at a utility
cost of minus 1,
costs 1 util because
the other activities
would be more fun to do it.
She'd rather watch movies.
However, if, instead, she
also has some other stuff
to do tonight, so
she doesn't really
have a free evening if she
doesn't write the paper,
but she just prefers not
to write it right now.
Now, if she writes
the paper right now,
she will get a free
evening sometime
in the future in a
few days from now.
And that would be
a lot more fun.
She could go out.
She could do whatever other
things she likes to do.
She could go to the symphony
or whatever she likes doing.
The instantaneous benefit, the
utility of getting a free unit,
is 4/3 utils, so it's higher
than the cost right now.
But it's in the future,
in some future evening.
Suppose Amy's daily
discount factor is 0.9.
Now, what does she do?
How do we think about this now?
So the daily discount
factor is 0.9.
Is she going to do it if the
free evening is tomorrow?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: And that's
positive or negative?
It's positive.
Exactly.
But it's exactly right.
So you have to think about she
gets the immediate costs right
now, which is minus 1, the
benefits of 4/3 on the future.
Since her daily
discount factor is 0.9,
she's going to
discount that by 0.9.
That's still larger than 1.
So she decides to do that.
That's how she
weighs, essentially,
the present and the future.
Now, in two periods, she
does the exact same thing.
But two periods are now
further away in the future.
So she discounts it by
delta to the power of 2.
And that gives her,
again, something
that's larger than 0,
if I got the math right.
So still she's willing to
do it, if the free night
comes two nights from now.
If it's in three periods,
however, turns out
then minus 1 plus delta to
the power of 3 times 4/3
is, in fact, smaller than 0.
So she will not do it.
So essentially, when she thinks
about costs and benefits,
it depends a lot on how far away
are the benefits in the future.
The further they're away in
the future, the more they get
discounted, and the
less likely she's
doing something that will
cost her utility now and yield
benefits in the future.
Now, of course that's
highly stylized.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Correct.
Correct.
So what I'm assuming
here, I was not
saying, when is the
best time of doing that.
What I was assuming is
choice between today
versus in a few days from now.
There was no option of
saying today, actually,
I'd rather do it tomorrow.
We'll get to that.
I was just giving you an
example of a very simple choice
between today versus sometime
in the future, and then
another choice between
today versus tomorrow, today
versus in two days
from now, today
versus three days from now,
assuming that other days are
not an option for now.
We'll get to-- so
procrastination,
you need several days.
We'll get to that later.
So again, the bottom line--
one second-- the bottom line
is she will do it if the nice
evening comes the next period
or in two periods, but
not if it comes later.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Doesn't
in all the periods
she gets more utility if she
rather gets a free day today
and she switches the options,
so she can [INAUDIBLE]??
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
Yeah, so what I'm assuming
here-- and this is, again,
an assumption-- is that
the free night cannot--
so I was saying a little bit,
but perhaps not clearly--
she has something to
do tonight anyway,
so she can't really
have a free night.
Maybe she needs to call
her friends and so on.
So that option is not
available right now.
You're exactly right.
If the free night came tonight,
she would do that, and then
do the stuff later,
because she prefers
the present over the future.
But I was assuming that
away for simplicity.
But in general, as it
happens, many choices
are often in the form
of either current costs
and future benefits,
and then you'd
rather defer those things.
You only do that,
essentially, if the benefits
are sufficiently high.
Other options are current
benefits and future costs,
and then the entire thing
is essentially flipped.
So now, the next
question, then, you
might have is to say, well, how
do we actually estimate delta?
So we see people doing
choices, but in some sense
in the real world,
we actually don't
know what somebody's delta is.
So how can we actually estimate
people's delta over all?
Let's stick with the
stylized example.
What do we need to estimate
delta in this specific example?
Well, you would need
several choices over time,
and then essentially,
you need to know
what the costs and benefits
of those choices are.
And if you knew
that, then you could
learn about what delta is.
Let me just write
this down for you.
Suppose we didn't
know Amy's delta,
but we knew that u
tau's for all periods
for the different
options that she has.
So how could we estimate
this from the above data?
So we learned,
essentially, over here,
suppose we see this
behavior overall.
What we get is several
inequalities involving delta
and involving u t's or u
tau's that people choose
in different points in time.
So once we have
these inequalities,
then we can essentially
just estimate what is delta.
We just back out what delta
is from these choices.
So what do we do?
Well, we can just
essentially do the math.
It's very simple.
And what we'll find
is, for example, if you
see that the behavior
that we just saw,
which was essentially
that she does it
when the free night
comes one day from now
or two days from now, that
gives us two inequalities,
the first two inequalities
that are written down,
which is essentially delta
must be larger than 3/4,
delta must be larger than
3/4 to the power of 1/2,
which is about 0.87.
And then we have a third
choice, where she doesn't do it
if the free night comes three
nights from now, which gives us
another inequality,
which tells us
delta must be lower than 0.91.
So if you saw those
choices, but if you
knew the utility of a
person, you could then
back out what delta is.
And delta in this case would
be between 0.87 and 0.91.
Does this make sense or
any questions about that?
So all I was doing
here is to say,
suppose we didn't know
delta, but we just
saw the Amy's choices.
What can we learn
about her delta
if we knew what the utilities
are at each point in time?
And if you do that,
from this behavior
we get these inequalities.
And we can then back
out what the delta is.
Now in reality,
we actually don't
know what the u tau's are.
We don't know what utility
is for different options
from people.
So if you see people's
behavior, we can't actually
estimate the delta from that.
So what could we do instead,
or what kinds of choices
can we make or can we elicit?
Yes.
STUDENT: If you can
do it with money,
there are different options.
You have a chance
to win [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
And what additional assumptions
do we need for that?
So that's exactly right.
That's exactly what
people have done a lot.
So this is Rick Thaler
again, a Nobel Prize winner
who has done exactly
that in 1981,
getting people to start with
hypothetical monetary choices.
So say suppose--
this is kind of what
I was asking you at the
beginning in the first class.
I was asking you
different numbers,
but what x makes you
indifferent between $15 today
and x dollars in a month, a
year, and 10 years from now?
What do we need to
assume for that now?
Or what other
assumptions do we need?
How do we go from
money to your utility?
STUDENT: There's an
old study [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
I need to assume something
that's quite important.
I need to assume utility
is linear in money,
either to say I'm just looking
at that specific problem,
u of X equals X. Or
slightly more complicated,
but in principle the
same, marginal utility
is constant over time.
And that's sort of related.
For our purposes,
what we're going
to assume for now is
just to say your utility
is linear in money.
You have X equals X.
And then what you can do is
if I give you an amount Y--
Y is $15-- and
then I ask you what
makes you indifferent
between X dollars in, say,
a month or a year from now?
I'm just going to write down
an equation, which essentially
is to say u of Y, which
is the utility of getting
the $15 right now--
is you're indifferent between
that because you just told me
so, and u of X, which X is the
amount that you just told me.
And now I need to
discount that by delta
to the power of t, which is
because it's in the future,
you need to discount that.
Once I know that, I know
essentially everything
on the left-hand side and the
right-hand side of the equation
except for the delta.
I can just back out
delta from that.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to just use, then,
the linearity assumption
of the utility
is linear in money, which
is like u of Y equals Y,
and u of X equals X.
We take logs on both
sides and rearrange,
and then get rho, which is,
again, the discount rate,
equals minus log delta.
And that's log of X
divided by Y and divided
by t, which is the time period
that I'm asking you about.
That's a simple algebra
and rearranging things.
We talked about a
little bit in recitation
and in the problem set as well.
But is it clear what
we're doing here?
Are there any
questions about that?
So just to summarize
what I'm doing here,
I'm just asking you between
different choices over time.
I'm assuming a utility
function of money.
So I'm imposing on
you in some way--
and it might be a good
or a bad assumption--
but I'm essentially
assuming how you value money
at different points in time.
And with that
assumption, then, I
can back out from
your choices over time
how much you discounting
utility in the future.
And then the rest is just
rearranging and doing
some math.
So now, how do you do that?
Here's an example of how to
do that, then, for Y equals 15
and X equals 20.
So if you told me
that what makes
you indifferent between
$15 now and X in a month,
if you told me $20, I can
just write down the equation,
and I get essentially
a delta of 0.003.
The reason being that
if you are indifferent
between $15 and $20
right now, you're
discounting,
essentially, anything
that's in the future by 3/4.
Essentially $20 in a month
from now or 3/4 as much--
or the money in the future
is 3/4 as much worth for you
than the money right now.
That's the 20 versus
15 in a month from now.
And then I have to
do this every month.
So every month, it's
3/4 to the power of 12
will give you something
like 0.03 as delta.
So I'm just calculating
the yearly discount factor
using your monthly choice.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So usually, what people do
is yearly discount factors.
So usually the delta is yearly.
That's just a convention.
You could also do it monthly,
or daily, or whatever.
So what I'm doing is
yearly discount factors,
partially because I want to make
them comparable across choices.
But you could
similarly also just do
the monthly one, or whatever.
And a lot of economic analyses,
yearly is the frequency.
When it comes to your
problem set questions,
it's going to be
daily, because students
tend to think in days,
not necessarily in years.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So in some sense, this is
what we're getting here
in some ways in saying--
here I'm asking you about--
so you see the choice here, and
these are actually real choices
that people have made.
When I ask you now between
Y dollars, $15, right now
and X dollars in
10 years from now,
people tend to give
different answers.
And one constant
finding there is
that people tend to
be more patient when
it comes to longer run choices
compared to shorter run
choices.
I'm calculating the
same discount factor.
And what I just told you
earlier is in the exponential
discounting model, the
discount factor delta
should be constant over time.
Should be the same
whether you decide
between today and tomorrow,
between a year from now
and a year and a day from
now, or between any time
in the future.
But what we find or tend to
find in these kinds of choices
is that people's
discount factor is
a lot higher in the future
compared to in the present.
I'll get back to that.
So actually, your question
is exactly on point.
When eliciting choices between
different days versus months
versus years, you get
a lot different answers
depending on what you ask.
OK.
So now, we can say-- and this
is exactly what you're asking--
let's see.
When you do this in different
settings, what kinds of answers
do you actually get.
And what you see here is here's
people's choices of delta
and different types of
experiments people have done.
This is different
years of publication.
But overall, what do
you see is essentially,
these estimates are
all over the place.
So you think we
know what delta is.
We think it's 0.9, or
0.8, or 0.95, or whatever.
But in fact, when you
look at people's choices
in different types
of experiments,
these choices tend to
be all over the place.
So that's not a good
sign for a model,
because you're trying to
identify a parameter that
fits many settings.
Well, here, it seems to be that
these choices are essentially
all over the place, which tells
you already maybe something is
wrong in this model that
we should try to fix.
Now, one thing I
already said here
is to say, when you
look at short-run
versus long-run choices, we tend
to find that people are really
impatient in the short run.
However, people are
patient in the long run.
There's lots to learn from this
experiment in various ways,
in part about strategies to
overcome self-control problems.
For example, a lot
of kids are trying
to manage their
attention, are looking at,
and looking away, and so on.
But mostly, I think
the key part you
learn is how painful
it can be to resist.
In the short run, there's
lots of essentially
short-run discounting
or essentially
short-run impatience
that we see in the world.
And if you think about it, often
it's very hard in the short run
to resist.
Often when you think
about in the future,
it's much easier to do so.
When you think about
choices that you
might face in your life--
be it marshmallows
or something else--
would you rather have one
marshmallow right now versus
two marshmallows in an
hour, you might say,
well, maybe one marshmallow
looks actually pretty good.
Let's just take that one
marshmallow right now.
And a lot of these kids, I
guess, opted for doing so.
When I ask you
instead, would you
like to have a marshmallow
in a week from now
versus two marshmallows in
a week from now and an hour,
it almost becomes ridiculous.
Of course you're going
to take two marshmallows
in a week and an hour from now.
What does it matter in
terms of when exactly you
get the marshmallow?
When I ask you the same
questions about one marshmallow
in a year from now versus
two marshmallows in a year
and an hour from now, it becomes
very obvious that of course, I
want the two
marshmallows-- unless you
think in a year from now,
you might be on a diet.
But the exponential
discounting model
has precisely that assumption.
The assumption is that
how much you discount
an hour in this case
does not vary depending
on whether it's right
now, whether it's
in a week from now,
versus whether it's
in a year from now.
And the short-run
discounting essentially
tends to violate
that assumption,
in part because it leads to
pretty absurd implications,
as I'm going to
show you in a bit.
So what other
evidence in the world
do we have about
short-run impatience,
other than the marshmallows?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
get concentrated.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
There's lots of-- I
think among you guys,
not that many people smoke,
but lots of smokers would say,
oh, I'd love to stop
smoking in the future.
I really want to quit.
But then they find it
very hard to do right now.
And maybe next
time in the future,
I will quit, and so
on, and so forth.
Lots of people try, and
then fail, and so on.
And in part, it's like
the short-run impatience
or short-run
difficulty to do that
compared to maybe the long-run
desires of wanting to do so.
We'll get back to
smoking, actually,
at some point in the future.
But that's exactly a
great example of that.
That's also true for other
drugs, other addictions,
and so on.
Actually, some of
the social media,
or computers, or
phones, or whatever,
you can also think of
like that being sort
of addictive in a sense.
In the short run, it's very
hard to get away from that.
But in the very long run, it
would be nice thing to do.
Often, then, there's
short-run impatience involved.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Taking a break
now versus [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah,
so a break now always
seems like a great idea.
And then in the
future, you're going
to work really hard and so on.
And then the future
comes, and again,
taking a break right now
seems really appealing.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Aggressive driving.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Oh,
that's interesting.
Can you say more?
STUDENT: In the short
run, you're impatient.
You're concerned
about your [INAUDIBLE]
so you might try to get
to the destination faster.
Or just in general, people try
to get to the destination as
fast as possible [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So of course, there's also
other factors involved,
including risk and the like.
You might think-- you
underestimate how risky it is,
and you might think, oh,
I might be overconfident,
that you're never going
to have an accident.
But exactly as you say, in
the short run, essentially
there's some short-run
benefits, which is
like I could be there faster.
It's kind of annoying to
drive, and so on, and so forth.
The costs are in the future
in some sense, so uncertain.
You might crash
and so on, and you
might be impatient in
the very short run.
That's right.
But I think that's a
little tricky as an example
because there's all
these other factors.
I do think, however, that
short-run impatience is
involved in that as well.
Yes.
STUDENT: I think credit cards
are also a good example.
Like, you can buy this now
with a credit card instead
of saving to buy the thing.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
So a lot of essentially
choices of money over time,
you can see the choices that I
was asking you guys in class.
That essentially shows some
short-run impatience as well.
There's perhaps even
more salient payday loans
that you might be familiar with.
So payday loans are essentially
a very interesting phenomenon,
where essentially,
there are workers
who get their paycheck
by the end of the month
or the beginning of
the month, but then
on the 20th of the month
or sometime earlier, they
would like to have some
money earlier than that.
So you can essentially
just say, give me
some money at a very
high interest rate,
and once my payday comes,
I'm going to pay you back.
The interest rates
are usually enormous.
Usually it's something like up
to 5,000 annualized compound
interest, which is insane.
These are huge interest rates.
It's also an enormous
industry in the US.
It's more stores than McDonalds
and Starbucks combined,
which I'm not sure how
many stores there are,
but I think there's
lots of them.
And people pay huge
interest rates,
and it's a huge
industry of doing that.
What's kind of funny about
payday loans, in some ways,
is actually in some ways, it's
an odd thing of the world--
that's sort of an aside--
as in workers have worked
already for 20 days.
In some sense, the
employer owes them money.
But instead, they're
essentially taking loans
from a salary that's
actually, in some sense,
theirs already anyway
in various ways.
But that's just an aside.
So that's a huge industry.
You were saying
something similar,
which is credit card debt.
Usually there, the
annual interest rate
is lower than that.
It's something like 20% in many
cases, sometimes also higher.
There's lots of credit
card debt in the US.
And you can think of
this as like essentially
signs of short-run impatience.
What you see is people
wanting to spend money now
on various things.
And they get the
gains of doing that.
The cost of that comes sometime
in the future when you actually
have to pay it back.
Finally, there's also some
evidence of payday effects.
These are often involved
in things like people,
for example, who get food
stamps or any other monthly
or other cash
transfers-- that people
get either food stamps
or money at some point
conditional/unconditional
cash transfers
at the beginning of the month.
And then usually, there's
these cycles in consumption
or also expenditures, where
at the beginning of the month,
people live large and
have lots of money.
Same is also true for graduate
students on their stipends.
The first weeks or months
after getting your paychecks
often is really great.
And then it sort of declines
over the course of that cycle.
The same is also
true, by the way,
for farmers and harvest cycles
in India and other places.
And then usually towards
the end of the cycle,
people either are hungry,
or have low caloric intake,
or are just not very happy.
That's a very common phenomenon.
And at the heart of that, there
is some short-run impatience,
in the sense of at the
beginning of the month,
you're really impatient,
want to consume
some stuff, and discount what's
in the end of the cycle, what's
further away, where the
costs are coming, then,
in terms of not having
enough resources or money
available anymore.
Here's some examples
of payday loans.
I was wondering
what this woman--
this is from wonga.com.
Apparently, they are
advertising with grandmothers,
because you wonder what
this woman is doing there.
But what you see here on the
right-hand side is essentially,
the interest rates are
something in the 1,000%.
These are the annualized
interest rates.
These are enormous
Usually people take
many loans of that.
They also take repeated loans.
So it's not just as an emergency
where people take a loan,
but people tend to roll over
these loans over and over
again, and actually pay
lots and lots of money
to these companies.
There's often very
high credit card APRs,
which 20%, 25%, and
so on are very common.
Again, lots of people have
lots of credit card debt.
And often, it's again, not
just to deal with shocks.
You might say, well,
if you have a health
shock or some other
shock in the family,
if people get perhaps unemployed
for a short period of time,
maybe that makes sense
to deal with that shock.
But often, people
tend to roll over
this interest for
many, many cycles,
and keep paying these
really high interest rates.
Now, in some sense, that's
just empirical evidence.
That's just a fact that
these things exist.
However, when you
think that through,
you get very absurd implications
of this short-run impatience.
So what I showed you now is
several pieces of evidence
of short-run impatience.
Now taking the exponential
discounting model
very seriously, we're
going to think about some
of these implications
of what does
the exponential discounting
model say and imply from that.
And one way to think
about this is the money
now versus later choices.
As I told you before, when
you look at number one here,
I was asking you
about what makes
you indifferent between $100
now and $X in two weeks.
And the median student was
saying something $120, $115.
And you can think about
what does that imply
for the yearly delta.
Well, it implies for the yearly
delta that it's about 5/6.
So you're indifferent
between $100
now versus $120 in the future.
So that must mean the
future is 5/6 as much worth
as the present is
for you right now.
Now, that's fine.
Excuse me, that
was the two weeks
that was I was asking you
about, $100 now versus X
dollars in 2 weeks from now.
So the two-week delta is 5/6.
Now you can think
about what does that
mean for your four-week delta.
Well, it's 5/6 to
the power of 2.
So that's essentially you're
indifferent between $100 now
and $144 in four weeks from now.
You're also indifferent
between $100 now
and $11,400 in a year from now.
And you're also indifferent
between $100 now
and I don't even know
what that number is,
but a very, very large number.
So if you think the
discount factor is delta,
and you just roll
that forward, you
get essentially
absurd implications,
the reason being that we
assume the discount factor
is constant.
And so that, then,
essentially, if you
are reasonably impatient
between the present and any time
in the near future, like
two or four weeks from now,
that must imply that
you really, really
don't care about what's
happening in five
years from now, and so on.
Now, that's completely
unrealistic.
The discount factor for
two-week delays in the future
must be, in some ways,
higher than the discount
factor for two-week
delays in the present.
And that's essentially what the
quasi-hyperbolic, or the model
I'm going to propose to
you in the next class,
is going to try and explain.
So why is that unrealistic?
Well, we know for many
situations in the world,
people care a lot
about the future.
People save for retirement.
People invest in education.
People exercise, often.
People do problem sets.
People brush their teeth.
People eat healthy, and so on.
People invest a
lot in the future,
in stuff that happens four
or five, six, seven, 10
years from now.
So they care a lot about
the future in some ways.
Yet we find the
short-run impatience.
So now we need to find some
model that can bridge this gap.
And so another
way to put this is
when you look at the evidence
that we have in terms
of my time horizon, when
you look at discount
factors conducted in
studies such as the one
that I just showed you, or using
real-world decisions, what you
see usually is that the discount
factor in the very short run
tends to be very small.
This is what you see on the
left-hand side of the graph.
When you look at
further in the future,
the discount factor
tends to be higher.
Or another way to put this is
the estimated delta increases
by time horizon.
Again, that's a violation of the
exponential discounting model.
So that's the first
piece of evidence.
The second one is
preference reversal,
dynamic inconsistency.
What I mean by that
is dynamic consistency
is essentially the
property that when
you make a choice for the future
between two future periods,
and when the future then
comes absent new information
or any other things
that have happened,
you will stick to that choice.
A formal decision
or a definition
here is, the action
a person thinks
she should take in
the future always
coincides with the action
that she actually prefers
to take once the time comes.
So if I make a plan
to exercise tomorrow,
or if I make a plan
to eat salad tomorrow,
I'm going to actually do that.
I'm not going to be,
actually watching movies
seems like a good idea, or
the potato chips instead
look better.
I have perfect
foresight in what I'm
going to plan for the future.
I know my future preferences.
And my future preferences for
what I want for the future
coincide with what I actually
want in the future, as well.
And so put differently, there's
no intrapersonal conflicts.
That is to say what I want
for the future is also
what my future self
wants for itself.
And so that's closely
connected to the assumption
of exponential discounting--
that is to say exponential
discounting has the assumption
that how much I care between
the present and the
future is always--
the weight is always
determined by delta,
and that delta doesn't
change over time.
So when I think now
about what I want
in the future, between
a year from now
and two years from
now, the difference
between those or the discounting
will always be delta.
Once the future
comes, the difference
between a year from then and--
at the time, then, it
will be like the present
and a year from now--
will also be delta.
So there's no difference there.
So what's the formal argument
of the exponential discounting
model?
Well, it is essentially
if at time 0,
I prefer an action
A over an action B,
suppose there's
different actions.
There's action A
and action B that I
can do starting in period one.
Well, if I prefer action A over
action B, on the left-hand side
there's the utilities
associated with that.
There's u0 plus delta
times u1 A of action
A plus delta squared of
u2 of action A, and so on.
If I prefer that over
action B, well, it
must be that I prefer
the stream of utility
on the left-hand side
to the stream of utility
on the right-hand side.
But now that implies if I take
away the u0, because they're
the same on both
sides, because I'm
making choices for the future,
and then divide by delta, what
I get is essentially, again, an
equality that at time 1, again,
I still prefer option A over
option B. That is to say,
if I prefer option
A over option B
at time 0, that
implies essentially
that I also prefer option
A over option B at time 1.
So that essentially is
another way to say it,
is that the exponential
discounting factor
implies time and consistency.
Any questions about that?
So what examples do we have
that violate this property?
We already talked about this
a bit in the previous classes,
but just remind ourselves.
Yes.
STUDENT: The betting
on how much weight
you lose when you're on a diet.
You make sure that you'll
want to change your behavior.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So dieting in general seems
a great example of saying,
I really would like
to lose some weight,
or have some target
weight, or some target
exercising, or a certain
behavior of eating
and exercising or combined.
And I really would
like to do that.
For now-- I mean, I
think about the future.
Often at New Year's
or certain points
of the year, our
birthdays and so on,
people think, OK,
I'm going to do this.
I have great plans and so on.
They have certain
preferences for the future.
But then the future comes a
week or a month from then.
People don't follow through.
Exactly.
That's essentially
a clear example
of a preference reversal,
which is essentially
another way of
saying preferences
are dynamically inconsistent.
Any other example?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
say we should
do something, kind of
like this is, like,
what we want our future to be.
[INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So that's true for,
did you say exercising?
STUDENT: Yeah.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah,
for exercising, exactly.
I'll show you some examples of
people, for example, signing up
for gyms that pay
yearly membership fees,
and so on, that tend
to be very expensive.
The idea often is
then they think
about they will go to the gym
weekly, or daily, or whatever.
And then under that assumption
for your preferences
for the future, then it
makes a lot of sense.
But then if you then
not actually go,
or if your preferences
are different,
then it turns out to be
different in the future, that's
a pretty bad idea.
Yes, you were saying.
STUDENT: So consider
apples or bananas.
If I'm choosing [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Yeah, to be clear,
if you just start eating
apples because you
had too many bananas
in the past, that's
not what we were talking about.
So it's not about
people's past choices
affecting future choices through
some form of habit formation,
or people getting bored,
or tired, or the like.
But it's about if I today
choose today I want bananas,
tomorrow I want apples, and then
tomorrow I'm actually saying,
actually, I don't like
apples, I really like bananas,
then that would be a violation.
But it needs to be
something that's essentially
either new information or
some new options or so on that
become available.
In the example that
you're mentioning,
there was none of that.
So that's not quite what
we're talking about.
More common is-- and there's a
paper that does this, in fact,
with Dutch employees by Read
and van Leeuwen that essentially
asked people about
next week first.
So it asked them
about-- this is actually
an actual company, where
workers were asked, after lunch,
would you like to have a snack?
And what snack would
you like to have?
Would you like to have
apples or chocolate?
When you're asked to do
that today for next week,
74% chose fruit or
apples, essentially.
So lots of people tend to want
to be virtuous in the future,
eat healthily, and so on.
When you ask them then
the same question--
so then in the actual
experiment, what
they did is then they went
back to the workers, and said,
oh, I forgot your choice.
Why don't you choose again.
Let us know.
That was a little bit
cheating, but then essentially,
70% of people, when it comes for
the same day, choose chocolate.
And here's none of
that, in the sense
of there's no habit
formation, there's
no people ate too many
apples and now they
really want chocolate.
That was only one choice.
And so now, when I
make some choices
for the future and
the future comes,
I should stick to that choice.
Similarly, there's
movie choices.
It used to be--
you guys are probably
too young for this--
Netflix used to send
you movies to your home.
But often what lots of
people had was this issue--
they had great plans of watching
highbrow, or high culture,
and often sad or deep
movies in the future.
There's really
things they wanted
to watch, be it The
Piano or Schindler's List
and so on, which
by some category
we might call highbrow.
But instead, when
the present comes,
people often like to watch
essentially lowbrow movies
like comedies, and
so on and so forth,
for example, Four Weddings and
a Funeral, Speed, and so on,
so action movies or the like.
And then what would
happen in Netflix
often is you would get all
these movies that you'd really
love to watch in the future,
but never in the present,
then get stuck with them.
And there's, in fact,
an example or a paper
who does this, which essentially
elicits people's preferences
for what they would like
to watch in the present
versus in the future.
And what you see,
essentially, is
people tend to
systematically pick
for the present,
for tonight, people
tend to watch or want
to watch lowbrow movies.
Action, rom com, or whatever
sounds really good for tonight.
When you think about what would
you like to watch next week,
people tend to pick
highbrow movies instead.
And there's lots of
examples of that kind.
And so just to summarize,
these preference reversals,
again, these are not really
possible in the exponential
discounting model.
That should not occur.
That's by assumption not
possible in that model,
as I just showed you
before, yet we see plenty
of examples in the real world.
Now, the third piece of evidence
is demand for commitment.
That's really closely
related to that.
So one example here is
demand for commitment
is essentially when you know
that your future preferences
will be different from
your present preferences,
you might engage in
commitment devices.
What does that mean?
You might want to change
the prices of your options
in the future.
And particularly, you
might want to take away
some options in the future.
One example is Ulysses
and the Sirens.
Who knows that story or
can tell me what it is?
Yes.
STUDENT: So basically,
there are these Sirens,
and they're singing
and [INAUDIBLE]..
But [INAUDIBLE] but it's hard to
tear yourself from [INAUDIBLE]..
So he had [INAUDIBLE]
tied to the ship
so that he wouldn't be able to.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, exactly.
So here's Ulysses.
I think he was on his way
back from his long journey.
He knew that the Sirens
were going to come.
He knew that his preferences
would change in the future--
that he would not
be able to resist
their power or their songs.
And so what he did
is he asked his crew
to bind him to the
mast so he would not
be able to leave the ship, even
if he wanted to in the future.
And that's demand for commitment
because he was taking away
some options in the
future, with a goal
to change his future behavior,
knowing that his preferences
would change in the future.
If you wonder why the
guys who are rowing
are not leaving the ship.
They had wax in their ears.
I don't know why Ulysses
couldn't use the wax either,
but anyway--
So that's one example
of a commitment device.
There's another one, which
is sort of financial advice
that people often get,
which is the following--
cut up your credit card
and store the cards.
If possible, get rid of
all your credit cards
or put temptation out of reach.
If you really can't do
without a credit card,
limit yourself to one.
Put it in a tub of water,
and stick it in the freezer.
And so the idea here
is if you really
have self-control
problems, well,
when you want to buy
something really quickly,
when temptation
sort of takes over,
you have to limit your
options in some ways.
So in some sense, have
you some cool down period.
It takes a while to get your
credit card out of the freezer.
I don't know.
I asked my wife about
is this a thing?
And she was saying,
well, haven't you watched
"Confessions of a Shopaholic?"
I have not.
If you want to watch
that video, you
see, in fact, apparently
that is, in fact, a thing.
But the idea of having
some cool down period,
which essentially is to
deal with essentially
short-run impatience,
comes in many settings
and many variations.
In fact, for example, if
you'd like to get married,
often you have to
go to some office
and declare that you would
like to get married, and then
wait for another three
days or something
until you actually get married.
Often, the idea is people
sometimes come to their senses
and it takes a few days.
So what do these examples show?
Well, they show that
people have a tendency
for immediate gratification.
And they tend to
discount quite heavily
in short-term decisions.
Now, what does the demand
for commitment then show?
It's we, in fact, tend to
disapprove of this tendency
beforehand.
That is to say we know
that in the future,
we might be impatient.
We don't like that.
And because of that, we
bind ourselves to the mast,
or we freeze our credit cards,
or some people, at least, do.
And so all of these
decision makers
are time inconsistent
in the sense
that when they make certain
choices for the future, what
they will want to choose in
the future will be different.
And knowing that, they will
restrict their options.
That is to say, different
selves want different things.
So then what's the
heart of the issue?
Well, the heart of the
issue is that there
are conflicts rooted between
short and long-run patience.
What we want in the short
run is different from what
we want in the long run.
That is to say when we
think ahead of the future,
we tend to be very patient.
There's all sorts of good things
we want to do in the future.
When the time
actually comes, when
we think about the present,
we tend to be impatient.
Now the issue with
exponential discounting,
then, is the exponential
discounting model
has only one parameter
which captures
essentially discounting.
But it can sort of--
by assumption, the
discounting needs
to be the same across
all time horizons.
That is to say, it can only
match one of those two things,
but not both.
It can only match either your
short-run discounting, but then
the long-run discounting
is off, or you
can try to match the
long-run discounting,
but then the short-run
discounting is off.
So what that tells us,
we need two parameters
to deal with that.
So what we want, and
I'll talk about this
a lot more in the next class
or in the next few minutes.
And then in the next
class, we want a model
that has greater patience
for trade-offs in the future
than for trade-offs
in the present.
And then we want another model.
So one is we want different
levels of patience
over different time
horizons, and we
want a model that
explains or helps us
explain dynamic inconsistency.
So what is that model?
So I just showed you before the
exponential discounting model.
That's just what I
showed you before,
but that's exactly the
same, where essentially,
your discounted or lifetime
utility is essentially
what's given here,
where we have delta.
It's between 0 and 1.
And delta is a short-term
discount factor
and it's a long-run
discount factor.
If I'm trying to decide
between t and t plus 1,
the difference between
that is essentially delta.
And if I decide between
t plus 3 and t plus 4,
it's also delta that
regulates this factor.
Now, what does the
quasi-hyperbolic discounting
model do?
It has another parameter.
And this parameter
is called beta.
And beta governs, essentially,
short-run discounting,
while delta is the
long-run discount factor.
What is that telling us?
Essentially, beta discounts
anything that's in the future.
So essentially, if you
look at the equation now,
anything that's in the
future, that's not period t,
is discounted by beta.
And then within
any future periods,
we have another discount
factor that's essentially
the long-run discount factor.
That's delta.
Now, why does that help us?
It helps us because
now we can essentially
separate short-run and
long-run discounting.
You can say short-run
discounting is governed by beta
and long-run discounting
is governed by delta.
And now we can
match a lot of facts
that we couldn't match earlier.
Any questions on that?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Yeah, I was wondering
if the evidence [INAUDIBLE]
was comparable to this.
Because if you have a
beta that really discounts
any future consumption,
would the commitment device
[INAUDIBLE].
Because many [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: So you're
asking two separate questions
here.
So one question
is, can we explain,
in theory, commitment devices?
Can we explain essentially--
can we write down
a theory that says
you should be at least
under some assumptions,
under some parameters,
willing to engage in
commitment devices
to demand for commitment?
The answer is yes, depending
a little bit on your naivete
and sophistication, which
we're going to get to.
But so you in
principle, at least,
can in theory write down a
version of this model that
predicts demand for commitment.
You're asking a
separate question,
which is are these commitment
devices actually going to help?
So A, are some people are going
to make use of these commitment
devices, and B, are
they going to help?
The answer is maybe.
In many situations, in fact, no.
The reason being
often people then--
they might demand commitment
but then not follow through
in various ways, which
can be then explained
by people are sort
of overconfident
when it comes to their
self-control problems.
We're going to talk
about this next time.
So the idea here is that people
might understand that they
have self-control problems.
They might demand
commitment devices.
They might say, I'd like to have
a commitment device to help me,
but they might underestimate how
bad their self-control problems
actually are.
So then they demand
a commitment device
that's actually kind of
helpful but not quite enough,
that's not powerful enough.
They demand that
commitment device,
but then they
actually fail and do
the thing they want to do
anyway, and essentially
have to pay money, or
other things like that.
We'll talk about that.
But that's not a
theoretical problem.
That's an empirical problem,
in the sense of in principle,
commitment devices should help.
They might not be able
to do so in practice.
Let me tell you
a little bit more
about specifics of the model.
And then we're going to talk
about this in more detail
next time.
So usually, we tend to
assume that beta is lower
than 1 and delta is close to 1.
So for example, we think beta
is 2/3, or 3/4, or the like,
and delta equals 1.
So then your discounted utility
becomes something like this.
So relative to the
current period,
all future periods
are worth much less.
So everything in the
future, essentially, you
discount by 2/3.
And then within
any future periods,
you don't discount
very much anymore.
Usually, we think delta is
0.99, 0.95, or the like.
So there's some
discounting in the future.
You care more about stuff that's
one year from now compared
to 10 years from now
or 30 years from now,
but not that much differently.
You care a lot about whether
stuff is in the present
versus in two weeks from
now or in a year from now.
And so then similarly, if beta
equals 1/2 and delta equals 1,
then again, your
discount function--
this is the d of tau that I
was writing down earlier--
is essentially you care
about the present 1,
and then everything
in the future is 1/2.
So again, relative
to the present,
all future periods are
worth less, weighed 1/2.
And then all discounting takes
place between the present
and the immediate future.
So then again, what
we can explain now
is essentially short
run impatience.
I'm essentially impatient
between the present
and the future.
Anything that's in the future
is essentially far away
or gets the weight of, in this
case, 1/2 or 2/3 or the like.
I can also explain
long-run patience,
because essentially across
the years in the future,
there's no discounting
happening anymore.
People tend to be
relatively patient.
And so then,
decisions, of course,
are very sensitive to the
timing of costs and benefits.
We're going to talk
about that next time.
So as I said in the email I sent
you, readings until Wednesday
are the [INAUDIBLE] paper.
We're going to discuss or
finish the same set of slides
that I've given you now.
Let me know if you
have any questions.
Thank you.